hi I'm getting a mama for developing
scientific content group are introducing
a new set of data or animal anatomical
structures including can I have a equine
Anatomy 3d models
hi I'm Kate Amara my photographer in
scientific content group today I'm
talking about a new set of data on
animal anatomical structures which is
available in the Wolfram language and
this is an expansion to existing human
anatomy data which was introduced in
Mathematica 10 yes sure that is look
good okay so this was introduced in
Mathematica 10 about 3 years ago years
ago and that includes detail the 3d
models like this for over 6,000
anatomical structures and this offers
good learning tools for students or
anybody interested in anatomy and after
the release of this Anatomy data we have
received several requests about having
more autonomous in addition to humans
and that was the basic motivation for
this project so now we do have models
for additional animals including dogs
and horses our overall goal is to
facilitate computable access to
anatomical knowledge useful for vet
medicine or any comparative anatomy
analysis this brief outline of this
today's talk first I'm introducing the
overview of the data structure and we
can access varieties or properties of
animal anatomical structures and we are
looking at some key characteristic
queries that use those properties and
some notable features of anatomical
structures there are hierarchical
relations and physical connectivities
and we are looking at networks of those
Asians and in addition to textual data
we do have graphics images and there are
some options that have been implemented
recently to customize graphical
visualization so I'm briefly going over
those new functions and finally our by
applying those tools and function
accessible in a Wolfram language we can
compare the anatomical structures we are
comparing some notable features both
quantitatively and visually using the
tools available in the Wolfram
technology and that brings us a summary
of today's talk and our data is now
accessible via the new entity type
called animal anatomical structure and
this data set includes computable
information about canine and equine
anatomical structures but some equations
are still in progress so the data should
be expanded through the other future in
the future and like existing Anatomy
data for humans and this set data set is
based on new MLS unified medical
language system which is a lexicon type
database provided by the US Library of
Medicine so this means that they share
the same data structure and same
concepts which make us easy to handle
their data and you're mentally data is
hierarchically organized showing this
simple diagram for example dogs pancreas
is structure part of trunk systematic
part of endocrine as well as elementary
systems as well as structure member of
the structure organs in the dog's body
so we can easily access the hierarchical
relations our information using the
various properties which I'm going to
show you in a minute and additional
information was curated by our intern
we have a host Kalina in your group
she's an animal science expert who
helped us create some of our data and
yes okay I was okay so for me we have
entities including muscles biceps
skeleton those are no one's entities and
we have wooden 40 properties to access
information about individual structures
and hierarchical relations properties
impurities constitutional parts property
where you can access the structural part
our bond is made of four separate parts
and the additional hierarchical
relations for example system group you
can get the list of organ systems that a
particular structure belongs to we'll
find the complete set of bones in the
body animal's body once we created it we
notice that there are not many data
sources that have the least complete
list of all the bones but we do have
information here but you know village
adult dogs have 319 bones and actually
you can get we can get the names using
our interface function what your
language input can be converted to warm
language input ready for the affiliation
so here the query was what are the bones
of the dog stepped
name and you get the list of bones in
this case left forelimb is the entity
and bones is the property and with this
entity property combination you get the
answer and similarly we can also ask
about muscles or particular Buddhism
segments and these parts queries we can
also ask physical connectivity of the
structure like a bones articulation or
finding a joint for given bone structure
so now with all these accessible
properties in mind let's take networks
of anatomical structures so here we use
constitutional pots property to get a
part of AB dog's body and one of the
parts a hind room is made of broken down
into even smaller sub component
structures including individual muscles
and bones and we can actually visualize
these hierarchical relations using a
single nest graph function and in this
graph the center of the graph
illustrates the dog body and this
Ranieri expanded groups illustrates the
body segments like head neck and behind
rib and there's some component
structures and in the next example we
use the same function but including the
tissue type structure type information
so now Muslims are colored in red bone
tissues and blue organs in purple so -
this kind of gives us that muscle
tissues occupied a large part of the
dog's body quite similarly we can also
build the networks of skeletal
connections here we use bone evasion
property to get information about bone
activity of those named and you make a
graph like this to show which bones are
connected to which but of course it'd be
nicer if we add bones the location
information and include that in a graph
and we can estimate the approximate
location of the bone using this graphics
regional central property and include
that information in the graph and here
we have bone skeleton connection graph
with coding it information included and
in addition to these texture data we do
have graphics related properties for
canine and equine on technical
structures we have models for over 800
and certain parts and additional image
properties include this body location
image and this regional location image
specify a viewpoint or you can also get
the highlighted of origin to get a
better view of the structure and this is
a small application of the use of the
graphics here we retrieved organs of
elementary digestive systems and
selectively visualize individual
structure like liver pancreas stomach
and so on and not limited to the images
we do have 3d graphics models and our
models are scared based on the other
lengths of female bones in adult animals
and coordinates are given in millimeter
scale and graphics including meta
information about some component
structures so for example this is the
lorry
made of several cartridges and you can
actually out the to tip with the label
for the subcomponents structure and the
source information and it's also
noteworthy that we do have capability to
do additional geometric computations
using mesh regions and the simple
example is planning a surface area using
the mesh also there are additional
building properties to access geometric
parameters like mesh voting and closing
to void ratio centroid and so on and
when it comes to customize the vertical
visualization we have not approved 3d
function and this function was
implemented by Jeff Brian
Jeff implement all the graphical related
functions who are not a mediator and
great thing about this or not reproach
3d is that you can add any constructs or
any combination or structure and it's
ensuring this entity they sting you and
the body food other the tooltips
included so you can actually see the sub
component structures and another notable
features of this another plot 3d that
you can artist iris there are specific
structures or specific tissue types so
with over here we specify the colorist
or particular muscles on the side and
visualizing in this graphics and in the
next example we specify that colors of
the tissues in this case muscles
occurred to be blue in dog's name and
also additional options to ennoble this
protein is very handy and nice feature
that you can
the scene of your interest to your
graphical visualization like this x-ray
a vintage style and in following example
we use clip playing options to
selectively cut external layers of the
structures to expose internal organs and
in this case we selectively cut muscle
and skin layers to expose internal
organs of the dog similarly here we
expose the internal structure of the
horse but in this case we use moniker
own style to emphasize the natural color
of material dance so now we do have
access to all the tools in fact Jonas
let's take a look at comparative anatomy
areas forgive an intermediate with
structural and functional similarities
and differences across different
organisms and we take human and a dog as
an example to compare their structures
this degree of similarity is first as we
might have guessed our internal organs
are pretty similar to dogs and here we
use anatomy plot 3d to visualize
abdominal organs in classic styles and
here we compare the limb muscles first
we retrieved the muscles of the
following important and then trusted
information to get the most human
structures and it's the list and we can
visualize the comparable Maragos muscles
of humans and dogs here and that there
are a lot of Samoas muscles between the
two in contrast some neck dogs next
muscles
quite different from those of humans and
we can get the list of those muscles
seeming in a similar manner and those
are unique muscles or feature in this
graphic where the those must also
highlighted in red and all the other
neck structures are in a more own style
and we can also quantitatively compare
their structures we don't know here we
compare the muscles noises between dogs
and humans and we compare the volume of
the muscles normalized by the body mass
and this plot converters as the dogs
have some muscles that are larger
muscles comparing to relative to their
body services and we can locate those
muscles using this location image and
these are the facial muscles some cave
muscles and it kind of makes sense that
dog has larger tail muscles attached to
the tail bone and well tail bones are
vestigial structuring humans and
similarly we compare the size of the
bones here and those of some larger
distal phalanges toe bones and these are
the bones and this table will simply
compare the number of bones and we can
not hear that about average dog has
total of 42 teeth this lower and upper
trees were humans of sorry - trees and
stalks having 26 ribs
certain pairs of ribs while humans have
12 pairs and the difference is in those
scared of next a schedule structures can
be visualized visually compared so here
we compared a rib cage of human and
twelve pairs of equivalent leaves are
highlighted in red and you can see a dog
has extra peeps here and these are
vertebrae we use scientific form to
color the individual vertebrae and you
can see up don't has long called out
vertebra tail bone which is prestige or
in humans and these are the Mandira to
know what is where canine teeth are
highlighted in purple as name stands
canine teeth in dogs are kind of
distinctive structures and here are
uncle bones in a vintage style and x-ray
style where the largest calcaneus bone
is highlighted in red so finally this
graphics kind of illustrates the
homeowner was scared of structures
across three organisms humans dog dogs
and horses and we can see that humans
have this color horizontal clavicle
bones where dogs and horses don't and
humans have this separated radius and
ulna bones while horses and dogs in here
are horses
those are kind of fused you can see also
the boxer here and the horses long
metacarpals and phalanges those are
homologous to human middle fingers and
this kind of doing us to somebody talk
we have new collection data which is
accessible via the entity timing the
entity framework in the warm language
and we have several properties to access
information like their hierarchical
relations and connectivities and
not to limit you to textual data we have
graphical images and 3d graphics models
and those can be customized for the
customized visualization and the
combination of the datasets and a row
from technology stock kind of allow us
to explore and compare them nautical
structures across various organisms so
what's next so we are kind of expecting
to add more information and more models
for additional animals so I curious to
know which of three models you would
like to see next
and I appreciate any suggestions so
that's all I have thank you very much
[Applause]